(sons de cloche)
- La fameuse cloche de 16 tonnes
de la cathédrale Sululul a
résonné dans toute la ville pour
rendre hommage à la reine.
Acclamé par la foule, le prince
William et Kate forment
certainement le couple royal
le plus populaire de la dynastie
des Windsors.
On ne peut pas en dire autant
du premier ministreBoris Johnsot
huer en arrivant.
Mais l'heure est à
la célébration, car pendant
70 ans, elle aura incarné
la stabilité, la continuité et
l'unité du pays.
Ils étaient nombreux pour lui
dire merci et immortaliser
ce moment unique de l'histoire.
L'émotion est palpable pour
certains, car ce n'est pas tous
les jours qu'on voit d'aussi
près les membres de la famille
royale, 40 en tout, durant
le service.
"On est déçu qu'elle ne soit
pas là, dit-il
on comprend. Elle a un inconfort
et ce ne serait pas juste de lui
mettre de la pression."
"Son esprit est là", rajoute
celui-ci.
(cris et applaudissements)
A 73 ans, Lcececece Charles,
son successeur est là pour
la représenter.
"Nous sommes heureux que vous
soyez bien en selle", lance
l'archevêque de York durant
la cérémonie, faisant référence
à l'amour de la reine pour
les chevaux.
Seul absent, le prince Andrew
qui aurait été déclaré positif
de la COVID-19.
Le Prince Harry et Meghan
Markle étaient présents même
s'ils ont renoncé à leurs titres
royaux.
"Je ne les soutiens pas du
tout", dit-il.
"Ils ne devraient pas être
ici", dit celle-ci.
"Je campe depuis trois nuits,
dit cette Albertaine, qui a fait
le voyage de Grand Prairie,
je n'ai eu que 3 heures de
sommeil, chaque nuit."
Un jubilé qui pour un moment
fait oublier les tracas
quotidiens et l'actualité avec
son lot de mauvaises nouvelles :
l'inflation, la pandémie,
la guerre en Ukraine. Comme si
le Royaume-Uni s'était arrêtée
dans le temps pour marquer
cet anniversaire.
La reine est absente pour
la plupart des festivités,
mais présente dans le coeur
des britanniques qui vont la
célébrer tout au long de la fin
de semaine. D'ailleurs, un grand
concert est prévu demain soir
pour lui rendre hommage, et
elle risque une fois de plus de